all right let's go back to the phones
let's go to lauren in columbus
ohio lauren how are you hi dr john i'm
doing well thank you
outstanding how are you this morning
well i'm
okay i just have a quick concern
i'm recently divorced and my ex and i
have a two-year-old son
i'm struggling with the example that my
ex sets
for him and i i don't do well with
keeping my opinions to myself
still kind of have that spousal i don't
i don't either that's why we started a
radio show because i can't keep my
opinions to myself
so i just need help with that so you've
got a two-year-old is your two-year-old
splitting time between the two of you
yeah equally equally so what are some
behaviors you're concerned with or what
are some examples you're concerned with
um there are two main ones my
my hebrew knots my ex won't let me
even step into his house when we do the
switch over
um just feels very protective of
um his space i guess um and my son can
see that
and then secondly if if my ex is dating
someone
you know once or twice it doesn't matter
how many times
or how many people he will introduce our
son to that
new person and that really bothers me
so does it bother you for your son or
does it bother you
that he's dating again
no that does not that doesn't matter to
me that he's dating someone
i just don't want my son to be
thinking that that's okay to you know i
don't want him to
to gain a relationship with somebody and
they're not going to be sticking around
perhaps yeah that's definitely
challenging have you sat down with your
ex and had that kind of conversation
yes uh and he says it's none of my
business
so i would strongly i'm smiling here um
not out of funny but smiling out of whoo
that gets me
gets my blood boiling a little bit so a
hundred percent is your business because
that's your kid
it's a thousand percent your business
because that's your child
yeah it isn't your business he's right
on who he's dating
that's fair it's not your business on
who he chooses to
remarry or any of that kind of stuff
he's accurate there
but who is your child is in the presence
of
does matter it is your business
and that's nonsensical to say it's not
now
when it comes to what you can actually
do about it not a lot
not a lot um and so you mentioned that
whenever
you go to drop off your two-year-old and
you make the pass there
your husband doesn't want you coming
inside and the kid can feel that tension
there
my recommendation would be to not let
that be a tense moment for your son
because right now he's going to pick on
the pick up the awkwardness between the
two of you
if you don't feel awkward about not
going inside there's not going to be
awkwardness there
he will he won't get that tension does
it seem
silly probably does it seem like
two people can't act like grown-ups that
are co-parenting
right that just seems weird right but
the kid's gonna pick up on the weirdness
not on the social cues because the kids
doesn't know that it's not impolite for
people not to come inside and drop off
car seats and blankets and all that kind
of stuff
and so is less awkward as you make it um
the better
a couple of the rules that i like to er
just thumbs i don't say rules but a
couple of
pieces of advice i'd give anybody
co-parenting
after a divorce especially if the other
person is a knucklehead or
is just acting like a child is
never forget that this is his dad and
as best as you possibly can
always speak positively about his dad
or as neutral as possible about dad
don't ever put a child
in a position to have to choose between
one or the other
even if he talks about about you in the
future
hopefully he won't do that um and i
would also
never quit trying to um
have some sort of friendship or
co-parenting relationship with your
ex-husband and that may be hey can we
have a monthly check-in to see how
our kids doing can we have an every
couple of months can we go get lunch and
just talk about this is not a
relationship thing this is just to deal
with
our kid make sure we're on the same page
with doctors in schools and things like
that
i've got several friends who co-parent
that way and it's extraordinary
and then i know folks who just want to
you know clap you know wipe their hands
of each other and pretend the other
person never happened
the child the tragedy that is it did
happen you've got to be together y'all
guys have 16 more years of co-parenting
together
the best you all can do to get on the
same page early the better
um how long have you all been divorced
just since march
just since okay so this is relatively
new when did
he move out uh it was
february february okay so here's the
thing my guess is
the wounds are still pretty raw here and
there's still some
asserting of independence and i don't
have to do what you say and i'm this and
i'm that
some of that may be happening right now
and so maybe let some of that smoke die
down it's august so maybe
october november revisit it or shoot an
email and says hey can we
circle up it's been six months um can we
have a meeting for the kid
just to make sure we're on the same page
and maybe he'll be open to that maybe he
won't
but i would recommend doing the best you
can
to to continue to try to be a good
adult right and i said earlier said try
to be friends
that might be pie in the sky for now
hopefully down the road y'all can become
friends again and just
figure this thing out and be good
parents all for
your two-year-old child um
yeah that just gets so hard and guys
men and women if you get divorced
and you have kids please
for the sake of your children put down
the pettiness put down the
is my house my rules put all that
nonsense down
just don't that immaturity
that lack of wisdom that lack of not
caring about the person
that your kid or kids are going to
become is so
dumb i wish there was some other fancy
word it's just stupid
it's dumb it's acting like a kid it's
acting like a child
be a grown-up if you're going to get
divorced and you have kids
you will have to be in contact with that
other person
you will you're going to have to so go
to breakfast once a month
email each other kindly whatever you
need to do to communicate
but be on the same page about how you're
raising your kid
go to the same doctor go to the same
schools
have somewhat the same values as
possible and i know you're going to send
me all your cards and
and youtube comments or whatever about
last time we wouldn't have gotten
divorced so we could communicate that
well
you're probably right you're probably
right but now that you're not you got to
communicate that well right
um these are these are your kids they're
just more important than your petty
little nonsensical
i want my way i don't care about your
way care about your kids
care about your kids